what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Children of the Vault and
as always you'll find a link to the fall
of X playlist at the end of this video
but for those of you guys who are
getting caught up while the entirety of
the mutant population has either been
banished to the white hot room a place
beyond all space and time or those who
are remaining on Earth are being hunted
down by orcus and basically taken out
cable and
Bishop two really interesting and really
cool mutants are launching an attack
against the city why because the city is
home to hyper evolved humans who are
using this opportunity in Fall of x to
strike against Earth and basically take
over the planet so what they end up
doing here in launching this attack is
they take just like this Giant Cannon
because what cable and Bishop if not two
guys walking around with gigantic guns
and they end up firing off these micro
singularities towards the city right
manyi black holes now by no standard of
measurement is this expected to actually
work they don't intend for it to be able
to take out the city and in fact what
happens here just to show you guys how
hyper evolved these guys are 3 seconds
before the first micro Singularity hits
the city Mind picks up a small energy
Spike below its Southern border the city
Mind Of course being this just gigantic
computer that runs the whole place right
immediately three members of the city
are sent to basically investigate half a
second before the first micro
Singularity hits time slows to a crawl
and a sudden heavy night falls over the
city right 0.1 Picos seconds fraction of
a second after the first micro
Singularity hits one of them has already
sealed the singularity in a gravity
Klein bottle and the night lifts right
83 members of the city are dead and 12
city blocks have ceased to exist now
that's the crazy thing about it is
because if the other three had hit it
would have done some damage but by no
means was it enough to take out the city
but what happens after this is crazy
because bishop and cable jump in this
car with a minigun on the front which
looks amazing and they immediately
launch an attack against the city now
again they're taken out as well and
that's what's so cool about this is
because one of these guys is like did
you really believe an attack like this
was going to work right firing mini
black holes at us and then rolling up
here like Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome
with a minigun did you really believe
that was going to work and the response
of cable is actually no we didn't expect
that at all what we were expecting is
for this to do exactly what it was
supposed to do to be a distraction and
when this guy turns around the entirety
of the orcus force is descending onto
the city the whole of orcus right all
these Sentinels all these Stark
Sentinels the whole nine yards literally
it's 94% of solar particle beam absorbed
deflected significant damage stain orcus
forces incoming the cities under attack
protect the city and that's when Cable's
just like surprise so the question has
to be asked how is orcus even involved
here because remember one of the first
things that the occupants of the city
did is they kind of instill this quote
unquote virus if you want to call it
that but basically this kind of
subconscious and even conscious thought
in the mind of every single human being
across the world and in the orcus
facilities that are orbiting the Sun
that basically the children were here to
save them so there's no reason for
anybody to stand against the children of
the Vault it was a genius maneuver right
like why conquer a world by force when
you can basically use subliminal
messaging or a telekinetic or telepathic
virus to basically get them to see you
as their god well what had happened in
the last video when cable was freed from
orcus by Bishop is before he left he had
planted a subliminal thought in one of
its middle level scientists that
basically created paranoia and what this
guy would do is he would basically just
start to panic right he would start to
freak out that he would say there's a
massive Calamity there's a massive
threat in essence waking orcus up to the
threat that the city poses but doing it
in such a way to where orcus would see
the city as a threat and basically
ignore cable and Bishop and that's
exactly what happens right within 23
seconds this kind of hive mind right
these B brains more or less like really
actual like brains that work together
analyze the city immediately determin it
to be a threat and launch an entire
strike now here's what's crazy in
addition to the forces that they've sent
there we're told that from the
headquarters on the surface of the Sun
orcus sends down sa Hammer strikes each
with yat tons of destructive force now
to give you guys perspective here right
is I understand and I had to look this
up I had to do some research on this
right 2 seven yons is equivalent to like
540 quintilian right so one step above
trillion 540 quintilian Zar bombs the
Zar bomb is the most powerful Atomic
device ever detonated on Earth it was so
powerful it scared the heck out of
humanity like Russia was like we're
never doing this and the United States
is like yeah you probably shouldn't
right I mean the fact that this much
energy is being fired at the Earth if
this wasn't a comic book and even for
comic book it stretches the limits of
credulity I'm not a physicist I'm not a
guy that studies atomic energy but I
would have to believe a level of
destructive force on this scale would
like shatter the planet or set the
atmosphere on fire any number of things
right it wouldn't just penetrate the
entirety of the earth atmosphere and
just hone down rain fire on this city
and everything would be okay it just
it's it's nuts right it's just an
astronomical amount of power but
regardless of how you slice it it's
still not enough the city's able to
withstand this concussive force and it's
really just because of the level of the
force field that the city has and that's
why like you can kind of cook the books
and you can kind of make this work
because one of the things to remember is
that the city is Thousands if not
millions of years ahead of normal
Humanity the level of Technology they
have is astronomical right it's just on
a whole another level and so despite all
of this the children of the Vault just
tear the forces of orcus apart I mean
they rip these things apart piece by
piece and what's so funny about this is
for those of you guys who read Marvel
Comics back in the 90s specifically
xforce the relationship between cable
and Bishop reminds me of that because
there's this point where in the middle
of this whole firefight right this
massive battle on the city they're
arguing about their rifles they're
arguing about which one's more powerful
and it makes perfect sense because for
people like me who grew up with X-Men
the Animated Series and it's what got me
into Marvel in the first place the
biggest argument I would have with my
friends is whose gun was better cable or
Bishop right and like they're bickering
back and forth right like for example
Bishop talks about how the P 832 Z Point
plasma cannon was like an artificial
star or at least it used an artificial
Star as a power source and it's made of
self-repairing smart metal they only
made a few in the 43rd Century during
the beyonder Phoenix War right and the
response of cable is like I've got three
right the Omega pulse rifle is the
better weapon right that's the one that
he runs he's like the fact that I have
three of these weapons that you're
talking about and I still choose mine
means mine is better than yours so
here's what I want to know from you guys
in the comment section which gun is
better cables or Bishops you guys be the
ones to decide but we might even make a
poll right to get an answer to that
question but which one do you all think
is better but the fact remains here
right these guys for the most part are
able to hold their own but like the
whole bickering back and forth between
these two guys is one of these things
where it just it hits so well but really
it only impacts you if you were reading
the X-Men between like 2004 let's say
maybe like 2006 running all the way up
to like 2010 in the heroic age right so
like Messiah complex Messiah War Second
Coming the 12 lights X necroa like all
those different story arcs which we need
to go back and remaster those we might
pick like a day like Sunday still it's
just one of those really really cool
things because like bishop and cable
were trying to kill each other all the
time and they were like jumping through
the time stream and it was super dope
right it was really really amazing to
see but the fact that like it's one of
these things where even when they're
talking Cable says like this is where we
go our separate ways right I've placed
the map of the city I got from martio in
your mind right next to the sense memory
of the first time you got shot so that
you don't forget and he said says I'm
counting on you Bishop against my better
judgment and so the response of Bishop
here and this is kind of like the the
buddy cop type thing he's like you don't
trust me and I don't blame you right
like I literally chased you through the
time stream trying to kill you and your
adopted daughter Hope Summers and he
says but after all we've been through
all we've done to each other have you
ever known anything to stop me once I've
set my mind on something and that's an
accurate point because literally Cable's
like Fair Point here's the thing after
reading this I'll be honest with you
guys man I want to see a cable and like
Bishop buddy cop comic right where like
they're running through the time stream
like I want to see that man and so what
we do here is we pick up with saraphina
now saraphina is one of the more
powerful members of the children of the
Vault and the reason why I say that is
because saraphina has like the ability
to communicate with a control machine
she can control mind she can cloak
herself she can do all kinds of really
really cool stuff and in a world of
technology I mean she she could
literally take down the planet by
herself if she chose to right I mean
just imagine what would happen if it was
something like back in what was it the '
80s or the '90s when Magneto issued a
blanket EMP across the world it was
during a fatal attractions when he EMP
the world and like countless planes were
falling out of the sky hospital
equipment was failing people were dying
I mean it was mass pandemonium she could
do that exact same thing except this
time there's no way for Humanity to get
anything back online again and even if
they do she immediately takes it right
back down right so that's how powerful
this chick is powerful enough to kill a
world but what she does is she actually
flies above the city to kind of get a
bird's eye view of what's going on
because from her perspective none of
this should be happening Humanity should
be bending the knee to the children of
the Vault right they call them the
children of tomorrow their saviors the
people that will lead them into a better
future Humanity should Revere these guys
not be Waging War against them now one
of the things that does take place here
which I'm really excited to see is the
return of Mer 13 we don't really know
anything about this guy but what we do
know is that at some point this dude
went on like an antimatter Rampage and
just took out huge sections of the city
imagine what this guy would do on earth
right a living anti-matter reactor this
guy is kind of an answer to the question
what if blue Marvel were a villain right
like a guy who's powered by antimatter
and using any of his abilities could
just wipe out huge sections of the world
like that what are you do against a guy
like that right they bring him back
because it's basically a last ditch
effort even the citizens of the city the
children of the Vault were terrified of
this guy that's why he's called mu 13
there were only 13 versions of him right
for the other members you have like
martio 1131 right 131 versions of this
guy right 131 Generations there's only
13 generations of this guy that's how
scary he was so like they shut the whole
project down right they were like we're
done this guy's not coming back this
guy's way too crazy and deadly we're not
playing this game so it's one of those
crazy moments like I'm excited to see
what he does but focusing on saraphina
here for a second when she gets above
and she starts looking through
everything her ability to control minds
also comes with her ability to read
minds and over the course of this whole
investigation she says like I can see
that we are going to win this right I
can see that like we cannot lose and
then she says behind all of it behind
everything I see something else enormous
exterior to space arranging events like
flowers immense intelligence thinking
vast and terrible thoughts and she says
it's coming the Dominion now here's the
thing about this this can be interpreted
in a couple of different ways but before
we get to that point what I do want to
do is focus on what's happening with
Humanity because where initially
Humanity was unified right through the
singular ideology of seeing the children
of the vault as the children of tomorrow
now it's all starting to fall apart now
they're all starting to wage war against
each other right they're attacking each
other so on and so forth right the
message starts to divide what initially
started off as a coming together of
humanity is now turning into a
fracturing of humanity right so like
basically social media and so following
this you switch to Bishop for a quick
second when he starts to go against mu
13 but Bishop's ability is to absorb
virtually any form of energy and channel
it back there are limits so he's like a
glass of water if you pour too much
water in it it's going to overflow the
same thing with Bishop if he absorbs too
much energy without letting energy off
he'll explode what you saw in X-Men Days
of Future Past the death of Bishop
that's actually pretty accurate that's a
very accurate depiction of how Bishop's
power works too much power absorption
not letting enough power off he'll
literally explode right but saraphina
when she starts to realize what's going
on right starts to see like this idea of
dominion she says the city the humans
are not what they seem I must warn the
city our strategies are compromised our
information incomplete and she goes
running into the core right City do you
hear me the humans are not alone they're
not even in control it wears them like a
glove a mind Beyond Comprehension forces
their every move and that's when this
person comes out of nowhere and says I'm
flattered but you're giving me too much
credit forces their every move nobody
held a gun to their head that's when we
find out it's cable this is such an
important thing right because something
to know about cable this guy's level of
power his telepathy and telekinesis is
on a whole different level nine times
out of 10 you don't see it because he's
usually always using those two abilities
to keep the technorganic virus right
that metal on his arm to keep it from
like eating the rest of his body and
literally killing him but in those rare
moments when he lets his telepathy and
telekinesis run wild and he stops
focusing on his technorganic virus he's
the most powerful telepath and telek on
Earth it's crazy how overpowered this
guy is and I got to say man if this dude
is really controlling the minds of
everybody on the planet all at one time
then it's good to see that this guy is
back to form with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end make
sure you click this link to the follow
playlist in order to get caught up and I
will catch you all later peace